une expérimentation d'ampleur va bientôt
être lancée sur le port de l'uniforme à
l'école voici ce que l'on sait le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel hatal devrait annoncer dans les
prochains jours un test dans notre pays
à grande échelle du port de l'uniforme
pour mesurer scientifiquement
l'efficacité d'une telle mesure sur
franceino ce mercredi 6 décemb il a
déclaré je ne suis pas encore convaincu
que c'est une solution qui permettrait
de tout régler et pas non plus convaincu
comme certains qu'il ne faudrait pas en
parler et l'essayer brut a demandé des
précisions au ministère qui nous a
expliqué qu'il ne s'agirait normalement
que d'un trousseau avec des T-shirts et
des polos leur souhait est que
l'expérimentation se fasse sans reste à
charge pour les familles le but c'est de
voir si l'uniforme améliore le climat
scolaire et le niveau des élèves et s'il
joue un rôle sur l'autorité à l'école le
harcèlement scolaire et les questions de
laïcité si son port est efficace alors
on pourra avoir un vrai débat sur la
généralisation de l'uniforme en France a
expliqué le ministre à la rentrée
Gabriel hatal avait demandé aux élus
intéressés par ce projet d'envoyer au
ministère une liste des écoles primaires
collèg et lycées où il souhaiteraiit
essayer le port de l'uniforme pour tous
l'âge des élèves et les classes
concernées reste à préciser dans les
annonces à venir